[Music]
guys a few weeks ago we celebrated the
goose bump inducing history defining
action you can only find at a csgo major
with our top ten major kills of all time
now look just because it's a major
doesn't mean it's all a squad jizz and
dirty flicks we've seen our fair share
of fails at that competition as well and
figured help
why not rank them cippec's has taken his
ankle you managed how to advantage and
he made start with aggression
if it was the other way around that he
probably went below 16 to 14 Darby take
it to the stew these are the plays that
well didn't quite go according to plan
so sit back and try not to cringe too
much as we give you the top ten csgo
major fails of all time kicking off our
list is na'vi zeus from dreamhack open
cluj-napoca 2015 with CLG on map point
the ukrainian IG l found himself in a
1v1 clutch situation with the bomb yet
to be planted and for reasons we frankly
still don't understand Zeus decided to
run through a Molly and well there's not
much more to say about this one Zeus is
awaiting that Ponte tendon it's going to
be soon it must be soon there's only at
this less than 10 seconds at this point
Zeus is burning he's burning no one's
going with colors actually gonna burn
Zeus to life what he didn't realize not
see what up just happened
did you cheeky tried to just walk
through that small table him
he was just taking the leap of faith
okay trying to go through the montage we
could believe it I thought JDM that's
what happened and Wow
I mean that is quietly dramatic you
could say I was looking at it but I
wasn't believing it because I call it
happened but it did not see coming in at
number nine is a play that proves that
not all miss plays are equal
courtesy of pascha biceps we've all
experienced that gut wrenching feeling
of getting CS goad which is why this
relatable blunder from the 2016 ESL one
cologne semi-finals had to make our list
and cold air has picked up the kid as
well her soul that he's picked up the
kid gonna buy himself way more time by
passion like so far off right now on
mini he'll just play the sound trigger
wait for the diffuse to try and come in
cold
he's already pushed out to try and find
it but many didn't see him because of
how far back he was he thinks it's
heaven he's staring and heaven he's
tapped in a way to pass just still not
gonna peek on this he's gonna have to
hold this it has to stick to the fuse
down to two seconds passionates hit the
shot
around SKR gonna get the pistol again
posture had the opportunity to take him
down then he wasn't looking at him try
to play the percentages market onto us
won the bomb down then I'll pay she has
no idea I'm here the full team piece
comes in is that kid we talked about he
picks it up five-second deep use and
crouching just trying to make the aim
awkward for Pasha there and he can't
like this shot we've all had this happen
to us in our matchmaking games but to
see it at a major is especially
heartbreaking which is why this mistake
comes in at number eight hellraisers
were in the middle of an epic comeback
against Team Liquid at the 2018 face at
London major and were on the verge of
breaking the cetys economy but while
walk sick was hopping mid bondic tank a
bullet to the dome
quite literally killing any chances had
a comeback keep in mind ladies and gents
at one point it's just twelve one two
liquid this is the only player to answer
back but he's been destroyed know what a
time to get that happening I know like
this just when it seemed are they
getting back into the game the team
killed from box ik coming in at number
seven is a classic Navi misstep from the
2018 faced at London major grand final
after taking a first half beating Navi
were looking to stabilize and this was
the round to do it that is until a
clutch smoke grenade from Astralis left
Navi doubting themselves leaving no time
to plant the bomb oh look at that
counter smoke from glaive it's going to
ruin the time ago Navi
it's going to be chaos moving into this
lowest site there is less than 20
seconds going into the plot on the lower
pond sight electronic gets a quick
pelvis hip X's position to try to stop
the pawn that's all he has to do stop
the plan Edward takes it down 8 seconds
to plant the bomb and they
stop it five seconds is up I'm gonna go
down in time oh I don't know if this
time here to plant the bomb Oh
[Applause]
god I could barely watch I could barely
watch smoke that is terrified Gus yeah
that's exactly that's not you smoke ever
what now that is the what now smoke and
the honest truth I don't know what now
coming in at number six is a miss Blake
courtesy of flush up from the 2019 IEM
katowice major with the 2v1 in their
favor and the remaining enemy out of
position cloud9 had all the ingredients
needed to spark a comeback all flusher
had to do was to fuse the bomb but he
failed twice when CT spawn he's gonna
move in but now he's got to turn back
and there's no way from to stop this
defuse this claw this round has turned
around about six different times and
unfortunately for phase they're gonna
come out on the losing end
flush it on the bomb and the diffuser is
powder vision good kill for a trend Oh
No but Trent has a chance flush her
normally so clutch and now the Trent
could get into the site he's sticking it
one more time at red certainly not he
gets up it once more dad Wren
capitalizes on the mistakes you will not
see that happen to flush a too often he
is normally rock-solid in his
decision-making he's normally ice-cold
and he'll he'll write or die but he
second-guessed himself I can only assume
he thought a dream was way closer than
he actually was
maybe it was a poor call look how close
he is when he gets off yeah I mean he's
literally just about to diffuse it and
he comes off the I'm speechless
the real heartbreaker is that c9 did end
up coming back but ultimately lost in
the 30th round will he just think the
defuse no he is he's going for the
defused eye comes off it he may have
been able to happen misses the noscope
and cloud nine the heartbreak of coming
back so many rounds been stumbling at
the last moment
at the halfway point in our list is this
comical mishap from sk-gaming during the
2017 illegit lanta major quarterfinals
down on rounds against faze clan the
Brazilians just couldn't catch a break
as they got completely outplayed by the
T side guys this is something you expect
to see in Silver level matchmaking not a
major now finally it's gonna turn on
them we have been
suckers that's a Kerrigan speaking they
just won the round by completely mind
gaming you as case like sit with that
and let that soak in for a minute you
didn't even see them in they wrecked you
taking the number-4 spot is mousesports
sunny at the 2018 elite Boston major on
that point against faze clan in the
quarterfinals Maus found themselves with
a two-man advantage on nuke and were
ready to take it home but the fin met an
untimely death which phase were all too
happy to capitalize on things like this
just shouldn't happen at a major
[Applause]
funny once they jumped off the craters
of all times to do this no not what you
want to do with Gordian and all off left
accordions gonna take down kristen 19 or
watch the oscars fell [ __ ] good turn
time beautiful he has to watch on and
let this round slip by the way sight
what happened that is sunny it must have
been transitioning towards her Ben jumps
on he jumps or here's a roofie mist no
wonder what's he done that for you don't
need to jump me this walk off and get to
Ulster huh I think oh I think he assumed
it was done what was he doing yeah that
makes pretty accurate I clicked that
we've showed you this one before in our
top 10 miss plays in csgo which is why
it comes in at number 3 on this list
astrologer thanking their lucky stars at
the 2016 MLG columbus major semi finals
as na'vi left themselves no time to
plant the bomb despite looking dominant
Cajun B you just had one job take him
down to one one now edward finds it free
5 seconds all he has to do is stay alive
shouldn't be time to Ponte do it he went
for the often steady he was hiding the
page I have no idea what's going on you
can see the look on his face he's
realized what he's done all he had to do
is stay alive and he didn't know just
stay admit even if you give up the plant
you still have a wall on one it's a
chance that you can still make happen
but you're right he goes out goes for
the face Scott Edward was nowhere near
it the bomb was there late our runner-up
spot goes to this lethal display from
the 2017 pgl krakow major semi-final
courtesy of astrologist glaive after
pulling off an excellent flank the danes
found themselves in a favorable to v1
post plant situation against gambit
esports that is until a trigger-happy
glaive gave gambit the opening they
needed to get back in the round glaive
with a massive flank he will hit a scope
as if it just has to hide glaive they
have no idea where
I can play on looking to play make a
championship later probably don't know
where he is yet
oh he's killed his teammate that mr.
real but it's no good for hobbit he's
got to make plays with to the point of
no return
and he does it dragged on the board
where's the communication dead talking
by pigeon mail and it did not get there
fast enough is I know like this is that
the round here that in the round time
will tell
not like this oh dear that's oh that's
such a big hole isn't it it's Charlie's
now in a position where they are on my
browser is still the opportunity to get
round number six you can see the
frustration they're taking the number
one spot is this brutal blunder from
snacks at the 2017 eleague Atlanta major
grand final snacks was about to
single-handedly bring the plow to
tournament point against a broken CT
side economy but let this play be a
reminder that greed isn't always good
the flank is sin Kerry gets the kill at
all on snacks he's got the triple he
needs the ACE to close this one out he's
ready with the 8k he goes for the spray
takes down the Knights are now turning
around snacks he's gone most out of the
sprays in pulls out the tech nine and
Kerry has to wait on the other side this
could very well be it ladies and
gentlemen the smoke is on the forum is
ticking right in front and there's a
shortcoming true Jerry with a clutch he
saves his druthers 1414 and with such a
tight score line this was B round that
BP just couldn't afford to lose well
guys that's our video you know what one
man's fail is another man's highlight
I've been thinking about this recently
it's like that Stewie 2k clip we always
show where he holds down the B site on
Inferno in the grand finals of the
Boston major he forces overtime against
faze clan make some good shots but
honestly faze clan entered the bomb site
with like seven seconds left to go so
for me it's actually a phase fail and
not so much a c9 highlight but it's open
to interpretation
just a little rant that's some food for
thought so go ahead and like the video
sub to the channel and let me know in
the comments below what your favorite
highlight that is actually a fail is
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button